il est improbable que les personnes
âgées par exemple parce qu elles se
savent à risque permet de faire des
formes graves sont déjà un niveau de
contacts très bas et donc pas pouvoir
les coupes et isolé 20 millions de
personnes de plus de 65 ans du reste de
la population en pensant que que c'est
la solution au problème surtout que
c'est vraiment regardé l'épidémie
seulement par le prisme de la mortalité
parce que c'est vrai que sont ces
populations-là qui décèdent du coc vide
mais c'est oublier qu'il y à beaucoup de
gens qui ont moins de 65 ans et qui sont
quand même hospitalisé en réanimation
l'âge médian c'est 67 ans donc il ya la
moitié des gens qui sont en réanimation
qui ont moins de 67 ans et il ya aussi
beaucoup de gens qui font des copies de
l'eau avec des séquelles qu'on connaît
encore mal et qui est qui risque de
poser problème dans les années à venir
donc donc cesser confinement très 13 qui
se veulent très précis ne résolvent
aucune qu'une partie du problème et et
sont des solutions malheureusement
temporaire dans tous les cas si je pense
aux au confinement localisée parce que
c'est pas parce que vous allez confiné
en plus seulement le week end à
dunkerque ou dans les alpes-maritimes
que vous allez
casser la dynamique de l'épidémie sur le
reste du territoire
or le variant anglais il est présent
dans chaque région dans chaque
département parce qu'il est présent il
prend de la place il va en prendre de
plus en plus et parce qu'il prend de
plus en plus de place eh bien il va le
faire remonter les il va faire remonter
les incidences et donc donc dans tous
les cas ce ne sont que des solutions
transitoires qui ne vont pas résoudre le
problème
[Musique]